no es la primera vez que el mediterráneo
se enfrenta a fuertes incendios a pesar
de que los de este año no dejan de
preocupar a las autoridades locales los
más mortíferos fueron los del 2018 en
donde sólo en grecia murieron 100
personas sin embargo lo que más inquieta
es el aumento de las temperaturas en la
zona grecia vive su peor ola de calor en
más de 30 años esta semana se
registraron temperaturas que
sobrepasaron los 47 grados centígrados
10 más que el año pasado en las mismas
fechas además julio fue el segundo más
caliente en la historia de toda europa
julio de 2021 fue el tercer julio más
caluroso jamás medido a nivel mundial y
el segundo julio más caluroso en europa
los expertos advierten sobre las
posibles consecuencias de la alza de las
temperaturas en el empeoramiento de los
incendios a nivel mundial la tierra se
está calentando lo que significa que los
periodos de clima cálido serán más
intensos y frecuentes esto hace que el
agua se evapore más rápidamente lo que
seca la vegetación y aumenta el riesgo
de incendios forestales vemos que las
temporadas de incendios forestales se
están alargando y están siendo más
intensas en todo el mundo
otra particularidad que atraviesa la
región es la devastación de la
vegetación en estos sectores
600 miles de hectáreas creo que se han
quemado en el día y el peloponeso y los
incendios alrededor de arenas han
quemado parte realmente hermosas de los
bosques que han sido los pulmones de la
ciudad
según el sistema europeo de información
sobre incendios forestales 56 mil
hectáreas han sido devastadas en los
últimos 10 años mientras que entre 2008
y 2020 el promedio eran 1.700 hectáreas
para el mismo período